6 41 here on a monday morning and you
know what valentine's day alex is coming
up this weekend
yes hopefully that's not a shocker if
you are still looking for a gift
we have some ideas with monica oh
jackson good morning monica
good morning okay john and alex before
you go away y'all already got your gifts
for your significant others or am i
putting your business out there
i i was waiting for you to come and show
us what to do
that's a good way not to answer the
question very good alex
no you guys know my friend i'm chatting
with the man known as the gift guru he's
the sultan of swag
he's created gift bags for several
different award shows
this guy's on the grammys bet awards the
oscars he's everywhere
for everybody lash fairy is back with
some great gift trends for valentine's
day 2021 how you doing my friend
i am awesome always better when i get to
see your lovely face
i well thank you i appreciate that i see
some fun stuff behind you already okay
so the first question lash cause you're
always on trend with this stuff
what are the gift trends for 2021
because i know they changed pretty
quickly
well i think the biggest trend in 2021
is that people are broke and have less
money to spend
on valentine's day gifts so you know a
lot of what i'm going to be talking
about is very affordable and it's ways
for you to get
luxury items at a lower price for
example one of my favorite gifts that i
got for christmas
is from toodaloo totes and this is a way
to take
actual authentic louis vuitton and gucci
and chanel and design
handbags that are distressed and old and
she repurposes them
into these amazing cosmetics bags
um that you can use for almost anything
so you've got a lady on your list who
loves leopard
and loves louie gucci all those these
are 75 bucks
from toodaloo totes um the other thing
is sentimentality you know one of my big
tips whenever people are shopping for
gifts
is that it doesn't cost anything to be
sweet and thoughtful and to write a note
that maybe the gift's not the most
expensive thing but it makes the gift
more meaningful so for example
gabrielle and company has this beautiful
circle pendant
that's two i don't know if you can see
it very well this is gorgeous circle
um and it's basically two intertwined
threads that are connected together in a
perfect circle so
a great little testament to the unity of
marriage and all of that stuff
for the guys and then i'm going to let
you talk i have these awesome
slippers from comatose so what's cool
about these is
they've got the sole of a sneaker but
the top
of a slipper so they're super comfy and
i'm in these all the time
i love that lash okay now you talked
about you said 75 dollars for
the first gift how much should we budget
because like you know i've been married
for over 30 years i'm looking for delano
to go all out i don't want no 75
gifts i want it to be much more
expensive
yeah it doesn't have to be expensive the
truth is that you should spend what's
comfortable
um and i think that that's sort of the
name of the game if you only have a
hundred dollars to spend
there's plenty that you can get for a
hundred dollars if you've got 200 to
spend
just spend it wisely so i don't think
the budget is so much the issue
as how you spend it so if you're gonna
get roses for example
i actually like these from rosebox so
while they might just about the same as
a dozen or two dozen roses that you
might get
these are specially treated these will
last up to a year
they smell they are actual roses that
are specially treated to last for a
really really long period of time from
rose box
i think that's the gift of the year i've
never heard of roses lasting that long
i actually had they gave me some of the
grannies two years ago that i actually
still have and they still look good they
were colored
gold so incredible the other thing going
to your budget question
is that you can do something that also
doesn't cost a lot so maybe you can only
spend 40 bucks
let's say and you're gonna get your
significant other tea because they love
tea
i happen to love tea too and cup of tea
these are two of my favorite gourmet tea
brands
so they're not crazy expensive but what
you can do is include a gift card that's
from you
saying you know what i'm gonna take one
or two hours out of your day on things
that you would normally have to do sit
with the kids during zoom
go run errands and you're going to get
to enjoy your tea or
take a bath using these amazing bath
bombs
um from totsy house um so hotsy-totsy
house bath bombs are the bomb
and then you just include something
that's your time and that doesn't
actually cost you cash
i love that lash i'm out of time last
question real quick here
what is the big no-no when it comes to
buying gifts for valentine's day
not doing it um so you have to do it
and don't wait until the last minute you
know so we're talking now you've got
plenty of days
ahead of you to get something lined up
and i think sometimes guys just cop out
like oh i'm not going to please or i'm
not going to try
make the effort and get them something
that you think they'll like
not something that you like absolutely i
love talking to you my friend hey
keep us posted on the grammys coming up
i know they were pushed back to march so
we'll be talking again my friend thank
you so much i appreciate you
all right folks hey and don't forget to
catch my moj show facebook live
weeknights
at 7 p.m don't forget we'll don't forget
rather we will replay
uh all the advice from last ferry
starting at 7 pm
this evening okay john sherry alex
all right nate where you at y'all got
the info so you can't skip out
john did you hear that for guys uh yes
john he got the memo
there's no excuse now right sherry i'm
telling the truth right and don't worry
i will remind them every day this week
i like the bouquet of cash with a side
of chocolates
oh i love you sherry you're a girl after
my own heart
then you go buy whatever you want no i
love it those are great gifts
great ideas especially the roses in the
box he finds all kinds of unique items
that's why i love having him on because
he finds things that you would never see
in a normal store he he really digs for
him and he does a great job